the coronavirus is limiting easter
celebrations in jerusalem for a second
year
in a row israel has fully vaccinated
more than half of its population
but the country's borders remain closed
that leaves holy sites without the usual
crowds of international worshipers
elizabeth palmer visited the city that
millions hold sacred
to see how it's managing here's a rare
sight in the run-up to easter
the church of the holy sepulchre in
jerusalem one of the holiest sites in
christianity
virtually empty normally it looks
like this packed with pilgrims who
believe jesus was crucified
and rose from the dead on this spot
[Music]
this year covered restrictions mean no
crowds
it helps us father louis cruery is a
franciscan monk who serves in the church
i asked him would that spoil the
celebration
no i expect the easter celebration will
never be melancholic
when we're not together it is hard
but the joy is the fact that jesus risen
from the dead
that's the spiritual view then there's
the material one
down in the ancient alleys of east
jerusalem where souvenir merchants
haven't seen a single customer for
months
this is what they're used to thousands
of christians following the via dolorosa
the route they believe
christ took to his death
but here's what they've got we met
farage
the first time in a year he'd opened his
shop hoping for some easter trade
this is for christian no dice
this is jerusalem in the old city
without
tourists no business no food
no nothing no life
on palm sunday a small crowd did come
out for the traditional procession
and religious service but these are all
people who live inside
israel the mass vaccination program here
may be
beating back coronavirus but the borders
are still closed
that's meant the american colony hotel
too has been closed
for a year this needs maintenance the
man who runs it jeremy berkovitz hopes
to reopen this summer
but it depends on the easing of travel
restrictions at home
and abroad it's a global economy we need
tourists from america scandinavia europe
britain the whole world but as long as
you have
most of the developed world's still
unable to travel
we are struggling for christians easter
celebrates
a return to life this year that's what
people of
all faiths in this holy city will be
praying for
too for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer
in jerusalem that's true israel is way
ahead of the rest of
the world in terms of vaccinations
they're waiting for everyone else to
catch up so they can visit again
i've never been i would like to go you
both have been it is powerful it is
beautiful
seems very meaningful too to a variety
of religions and it's definitely worth
the trip